let's talk a little bit more about Big O
notation and time complexity
specifically you're going to see Big O
notation with the O which represents the
function that you're looking at or the
algorithm whatever it is you're
evaluating and n which represents the
number of elements that are in that
function right now you do not have to be
able to look at any given algorithm and
immediately name its Big O notation or
write its Big O notation but what we are
going to do is get a little bit more
comfortable with relating a problem that
you need to solve with how that could
possibly be written in Big O notation
let's go over some simple examples now
oh the one Oh with one being n is an
example of a static amount of time that
an algorithm would take so if it was a
simple algorithm it doesn't matter how
many entries are an array the amount of
time that it's going to take to execute
that function is going to be the same
every time that's pretty much ideal it
really depends on your problem you're
trying to solve work that's possible or
not but that's a great and very
efficient way to do fix o log n these
might be some words you haven't heard
since math class I know what I've
started doing this I had a
divide-and-conquer type of algorithm or
a binary search is where binary
specifically you're going to divide up
whatever you're searching through into
two pieces and only search one of those
halves at a time that way you can either
determine where it is or you can rule
out 50% of the entries o n is where it
directly and linearly connects with the
entry n so the amount of time it would
take you to read a book directly
correlates how long that book is that's
not exponential it's very very
straightforward next o n log n that's a
merge search it's a little bit more
complex than a binary search so like
searching through a deck of cards in a
specific way you don't have to
understand it completely just know that
there are different levels of complexity
for Big O notation now I drew a bunch of
X's in between here because it's history
to get into the danger zone this is o n
^ - exponential and so checking a list
cross checking a list in which we
already have in your grocery cart you're
double checking two different things
you're looking all the way through your
list and you're looking all the way
through your cart if the entries aren't
very big that's fine but if you're
looking through every cart or the entire
store with a list that is you know the
size of the dictionary that can get
really really long really fast that is
exponential anything you're writing is
exponential and in its Big O notation is
probably not going to be a great
solution long term and we were talking
about scaling before think about the
future of your site just because it
works for you and maybe one other person
if you have hundreds of thousands of
users that is going to slow everything
down to the extent that it's not even
usable anymore that's going to be a
really big deal now obviously o to
infinity like I'm going to flip the coin
until I get a head that in the worst
case scenario another thing we need to
remember that could be forever um it
probably wouldn't be dependent could be
the first time but we're looking at
worst-case scenario here what I want you
to take away from this is using Big O
notation you can look at your code and
figure out if it's really going to be a
good solution for the future of your
site as it grows with more data more
users anything that is exponential or
below or depending on the algorithm
itself it really might not be very
practical